it was just like damn fool your dad's
really gonna come out I was like come on
don't trip and then he starts like
screaming in Chinese
you know what I'm like yeah this only
knows mother this month
[Music]
so this thing happened in China that
a little bit we could probably relate to
um this father was scolding his son for
getting bad grades his son's a teenager
so he's just yelling at him grabs a uh
like a decorative sword and starts like
poking him you know like yelling at him
about his grades because he got like an
FNP samurai sword right uh it's like
it's a three foot blade so whether that
sounds pretty big dude yeah that's a big
that's a big blade might be yeah it
ain't a little boo but it's uh you know
yeah right and yelling at him and he
accidentally like like pokes him like on
his midsection makes about a four inch
uh
and then the kid starts bleeding to
death and they can't stop it oh okay and
the boy dies
whoa dude hey was it that like I was
just playing
I mean the father did say he didn't mean
to do it like he didn't mean to uh
actually like stab him like he didn't
mean to cut him that bad I'm trying to
poke him I wanted to scare him then it
[__] went in there's there's like I
think the kid had two lacerations one of
them was very small and the other one
was the Fatal laceration around his
midsection why like but it wasn't like a
it definitely was not a uh he didn't
restrain him and like give him a slice
he was like berating him yelling at him
they they ended up looking into this
kid's like uh when they do the forensics
and they find out like there are other
times where he may have like punched
them or like hurt him yeah like as
punishment but that's definitely like
way way way over yeah
so I a sword is crazy the father ended
up doing I think I think I sentenced
like 14 years for the yeah for his son's
I guess it would be like I don't even
know if that's an adequate like sentence
or not yeah I don't know it's a Chinese
one but uh I don't know if that what's
the max for for um is in China that type
in China maybe in China they go you do
the full full team you know it's not
like here
because when we say 14 it's 14 okay
[__] or maybe it's [__] like Chinese
America when we say 14 we mean 16 okay
oh because they have to overachieve oh
yeah
like yeah I'm leaving today like no yeah
right two more years you're like what
the [__]
he just moved the goal posts oh yeah
right yeah right yeah you didn't suffer
enough you must be dreaming
stupid
the funny like relatability that that
oddly that I have for this story is that
like when I was a kid and my dad was
like pushing me or like yelling at me or
doing stuff I would always be like oh I
hope you mess up and you hurt me like
real bad so I can like be like oh look
what you did and then you die out yeah I
didn't want to die but I'm like you know
you always hope that you can turn the
tide a little bit with something where
like they'll come back and be like I'm
sorry I didn't mean it but you know this
is like it's like man I didn't mean it I
just wanted to scare him it's like with
a deadly weapon yeah I just think that's
pretty stupid yeah they're just levels
to this you know like everyone knows you
don't poke them with it you just get
right into their face with it like you
don't yeah [__] make contact it's
kind of weird yeah bro it's like yeah
you're gonna you're on a swordsman why
is your decorative sword sharp enough
but did you guys have you guys had the
sword thing on the stand at your houses
when you were growing up yeah was that
an Asian joke dude
that's not funny dude well yeah it's
usually next to the gong no
you guys never had that no like uh
because I I had swords but not because
my parents had swords to [__]
threaten me to study I had sourced
because I was a nerd and wanted some
swords you know what I mean like it's
different you're the cloud Sorter and my
parents aren't gonna be like yeah hang
your [__] swords up on the wall
Anthony no they don't [__] do that
in the living room it'll tie the room
together yeah I'm gonna [__] freak
you out so that you can study better
like my mom threatened me with a Cleaver
once when I was a kid my mom's like yeah
did she saying that you she like put it
up to my face yo like like real and she
was pissed what did you why what was the
reason what I did my mom was swinging at
I was probably doing some crazy [__] I
had the body Slammer ass [__] dude I
bought it something on the couch to have
a soft landing
and she had the knife in her hand doing
that yeah no no yeah she was she was
like I mean this was like maybe when I
was like a freshman or a sophomore so I
was like pretty cuckoo and so I think my
mom was just being a single mom was just
she was like probably had enough of my
[__] too she lost it yeah she lost it
and I was like man this [__] [__]
crazy
actually I picked a body slammed her and
then I [__] went out with the homies
I remember coming back I went out with
the homie oh dude I remember coming back
home at 3am my mom you know you know my
Studio's house yeah my mom's was sitting
on the front line in her [__]
bathroom like this
my home is dropping me off and like dude
your mom's [__] tripping I'm like I
know she's like this every day
you she must have lost your her mind
with you as a son no dude I was like
have you guys talked about that recently
because I know you're like patching up
and like talking about a lot of stuff
yeah we've been patching stuff up but
remember when you had a Cleaver and I
body slammed you on the couch how did
that conversation yeah
you were tripping she was probably
buried a lot of memories just like how I
buried a lot of my own memories just
during that period yeah but then when I
bring it up of like some of the stuff
that she did like like uh when she was
staying at my house
she was like cutting uh with The Cutting
Board I'm like whoa whoa whoa and my mom
starts laughing yeah
[Laughter]
like don't [__] bring that up like oh
that's the next level bro yeah you don't
ever act like you're gonna slam her
again
[Laughter]
it's fun that you could laugh about
stuff so sweet and I was so heavy back
in the day right yeah I think that's the
only way to really deal with that [__]
like you and your dad like since you you
can now speak freely about a lot of
things yeah you probably didn't touch so
much of that all this time huh yeah bro
I mean we we do talk about stuff like
that which is kind of crazy like the way
that me and my pops are now we're super
open with with each other you know yeah
like and that's that's tough like
because even my brother he did a lot of
stuff to my brother too but my brother
is a firstborn so you know in the
Chinese culture like they carry the
firstborn like the most responsible they
love them and stuff you know yeah and
the younger ones it's like I had to tell
my brother like like I had to call him
like Google right which is older bro but
I'm like bro we're from America bro I'm
gonna call you James bro yeah yeah you
know like and like I would like get beat
up because my I wouldn't respect him and
my brother could do whatever he wanted
to me as a kid and if I if I like smack
them back or it's over it's over I'll
get beat up by my brother and I'll get
beat up by my deck right yeah so that
was crazy bro damn everybody was beating
each other up in the 90s like yeah that
just was the theme bro no cell phones
man that's why yeah yeah no iPhones
right now
does your family speak Cantonese or man
yeah Mandarin Chinese they're actually
born in Korea though because they like
they're so my grandparents like fled the
war you know fled communism and all that
and then landed in Korea they had a flat
flat I could fly go away again when Kim
Jong-il came into Power yeah whatever
[Laughter]
are you able to laugh about crazy [__]
that you guys probably did back in the
day yeah because recently we were
talking about it like he did the same
like what BART was talking about like my
dad did some [__] like that he he would
always walk around so we have this house
broom but it's like a short broom I
don't know if you guys ever seen that
right with a bunch of sticks yeah yeah
so he would always yeah it's so
effective it was bro but one time same
thing I was I got into argument with him
and I was like I'm leaving this house
and I ran away for a little bit then
like I came home I think it was like 12
1am right and then this dude was waiting
my dad was waiting outside and he was
like chasing my homies oh [__] my homies
oh yeah he [__] you and your friends
up but at that time I remember the rage
I felt because your homies are
everything at that time yeah and you're
just like
[__] stop like I was screaming at him
I was like yeah and then at that time
I'm not happy about it but I pulled the
strap on my dad oh [__] and then I was
like and then that's what my dad just
kind of like what the hell dude like he
froze up a little bit and then he just
kind of turned around and walked away
and then my homies were like hey bro
like that's not you know what I mean
like that's not they're just taking the
hits because they're like is respect
it's your dad is [__] it yeah but then
it wasn't their favorite thing right
like for having pts
my dad Beat Me Harder
it's okay we'll take it that's true
homies though right but they were you
know that's the different element now
it's like although we like like he said
you know he threw his mom onto the couch
yeah where his kids nowadays like [__]
you mom
they don't care you know so yeah I think
it was there was still that level of
respect even though they were gang
members you know we had to kind of still
respect our elders a little bit right
you know so but I had just lost it bro I
had lost it because it was so
embarrassing yeah it was just like damn
fool your dad's really gonna come out I
was like come on don't trip and then he
starts like screaming in Chinese yo
mother [__]
you know what I'm like yeah this only
knows mother this month
do you and your dad now like joke about
it the way him and his mom might like
your dad just pulls out a gun
he still has the broom
[Music]
no but he always say stuff like you were
wild back then and I'm like yeah I know
pops you know it's crazy yeah but he he
would he always feels that kind of guilt
because my dad was an alcoholic so he
felt like you know at least like 50 of
it was on him because he would just beat
us for no reason I mean there's times
where he would just like rage you know
and I mean but now that we think about
it he doesn't drink anymore which is
like amazing he comes to church you know
and so he's like damn like that's so
crazy you know like it's like that you
know basically in the past now yeah yeah
it's so cool to look at it that way and
I always just make fun of his accent
like I know that's messed up
you know oh for sure yeah like one time
he was at Home Depot go to and like
Chinese people were freaking cheap bro
like it's all money in no money out
right so like he was trying to bargain
at Home Depot I never I was a kid like
at that time I remember like 10 or 11
years old and he's like the drill was I
don't know 50 bucks he's like 25. and
the guy was just like bro is this food
really trying to yeah he's like no it
has the boxes broken like what the [__]
he's like yeah you did that he's trying
to like bargain it you know can we get a
discount on this and that and then I was
just like damn to us it was normal but
now that I think about it I'm like pops
like you did some crazy stuff your dad
ever go hey Johnny put your gun at him
man
my son's gonna shoot you
now it's free
[Laughter]
that's how we do it
[Music]
foreign